Welcome to "English in a Minute."
If you have ever heard people saying goodbye in American English,...
...you probably have heard this: "Make sure to stay in touch."
People who don't see each other often like to find ways to "stay in touch."
But what does that mean?
It was great to see you at the class reunion.
Now make sure to stay in touch.
I want to talk to you before our next reunion.
I will.
I'll stay in touch and I'll call you sometime next week.
"Staying in touch" or "keeping in touch" says that you want to communicate with someone.
It means you want to keep in contact, maybe by phone or e-mail,...
...even though you don't see that person often.
Make sure to stay in touch.
And that's "English in a Minute."